-Welcome, welcome, welcome,
welcome to "The Tonight Show."
You're here. You're watching.
Thank you.
Well, guys, some big box office
news.
The final numbers are in and
"Creed III" just had the biggest
ever opening weekend
for a sports movie.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Biggest ever.
That is a huge deal.
I mean, it almost feels like
a "Miracle."
I bet Michael B. Jordan was
totally "blindsided" by the news
that the movie made over
100 "Million Dollar, Baby,"
which makes sense.
The "Creed" movies are in
"a league of their own."
The whole time you're like,
will he win?
I think he might.
He "ducks," left, right."
[ Laughter ]
He's so "cool, running"
super fast in every montage.
So congrats, Michael.
It is amazing to see
"Ali's" accomplished --
"Ali's [all he's]" accomplished.
a lot of people thought acting
and directing
might be "rocky" for you,
but you're no "rookie."
You had confidence to say,
"bring it on."
They weren't sure if you could
take the torch from Stallone,
but it's official.
You're his true "air, bud."
[ Laughter and applause ]
Though I got to ask, "Hoosier"
[who's your] accountant?
Because they got to be working
overtime burning
the "Friday night lights" until
"any given Sunday."
Anyway, I hope you can relax,
get some "space, jam"
on some other projects and sip
a piña colada with
one of those silly straws where
you can "bend it like Beckham."
There you go. Thank you.
Congratulations, buddy.
[ Cheers and applause ]
That's right. Come on.
-Come on.
-Thank you very much.
That's right, "Creed III" had
the biggest opening
ever for a sports movie.
And I think seeing Michael B.
Jordan has inspired some people
to hit the gym and get in shape.
Check out what I saw earlier
today.
-I signed into law the landmark
American Rescue Plan,
which provided the resources to
get COVID-19 under control.
-That's interesting, right?
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Wow.
-Speaking of sports,
this is going viral.
[ Laughter ]
-He's swollen --
-You have a great laugh.
Whoever's laughing at that,
I love that. Great laugh.
This is going viral.
On a recent episode of
"Jeopardy!",
there was a category called
"In the Sport."
Did you see this today?
-Unh-unh.
-None of the contestants could
answer any of the questions.
[ Laughter ]
This is real.
Take a look at this. Watch this.
-What is roulette?
[ Buzzer ]
-That would be polo.
That's hockey.
[ Buzzer ]
That's boxing.
-What is water polo?
[ Buzzer ]
-That's golf.
That's baseball.
[ Laughter ]
-Wow!
That was so funny.
Yep, that beloved American
sport, roulette.
-Ah.
-That's a great sport.
[ Laughter ]
After the show, they were all
stuffed in a locker
by contestants from
"Wheel of Fortune."
Like, "Get in there, nerd!"
[ Laughter ]
Some political news -- Former
president Trump is strongly
considering a woman to be
his vice President so that
he can win over suburban women.
Of course, since it's Trump,
he'll make the decision after
holding a "Miss Vice President"
pageant.
[ Laughter ]
Hey, did you guys see this?
Today, the Justice Department
filed a lawsuit to block
JetBlue's merger
with Spirit Airlines.
It's actually positive news
because lately, when we hear
about JetBlue merging with
another airline,
it's on the runway.
[ Laughter ]
[ Audience ohs ]
Hey guys, listen to this.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh!
-Amid a nationwide bird flu
outbreak,
the Biden administration is
considering
mass poultry vaccination.
[ Laughter ]
It will be weird when KFC
says their chickens are all
"vaxed and waxed."
[ Laughter ]
That's right.
They're gonna give vaccines to
chickens, although not all
chickens are on board.
One of them said...
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Wow.
-That's a long hashtag.
-Some business news -- I read
that Hershey's
is launching a vegan Reese's
Peanut Butter Cup.
I think the bigger story here
is,
there's meat inside Reese's
Peanut Butter Cup?
What the hell is going on?
Guys, I saw that Sunny D is
releasing its own line of
canned vodka seltzer.
[ Audience oohs ]
I think it started a trend
because now other kids'
companies are trying to branch
out into the hard beverage
world, but I don't know if it's
such a good idea.
Take a look at some of
these other drinks here.
First up, there's
Franzia by the Foot.
[ Laughter ]
Next up, there's YooHooch.
YooHooch.
-YooHooch.
Oh, my.
-There's also
Gin & Juicy Juice.
[ Laughter ]
Up next, we have
Whiskey Sour Patch Kids.
[ Laughter ]
And finally, Bud Pedialyte.
And you go well,
that's too much.
You've gone too far.
I would do the Bud one.
Meanwhile, a popular beer in
Australia is being recalled
because it was found to have
too much alcohol.
Yeah, it's the first recall that
made people go out and buy more.
[ Laughter ]
Guys, finally, it is Tuesday.
It is time for "WeTweet."
Here we go.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-♪ WeTweet ♪
♪♪
♪ WeTweet ♪
-Welcome to "WeTweet."
This is where we as a group
decide something
that we should post on Twitter.
I'm going to show you a series
of different tweets.
Then we're all going to vote on
whether you like
each one or not.
You all have voting clickers
at your seats.
You can vote for all of them.
You can vote for none of them.
Whatever you want, but we're
going to see the results
live here on the show.
Higgins, Roots,
you guys have your clickers too?
-Got it.
-Whatever tweet
gets the most likes,
we will tweet it out
live on the show
so that you can all like it
and "WeTweet" it.
It's a shared experience.
Okay, you guys ready for this?
[ Cheers ]
Alright.
The first tweet is...
[ Light laughter ]
♪♪
-[ Chuckles ] Wow.
-"Get in --
Get in that locker, nerd!"
[ Laughter ]
-Alright. Here we go.
Everyone has made
their decision.
The votes are in.
Let's see the results here.
[ Drum roll ]
Alright, okay.
Half and half.
Okay.
Lukewarm reception to that one.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah. Tepid, tepid.
-Alright, this next one is...
[ Laughter ]
See, is it corn pops?
Okay, I feel like everyone kind
of made their decision fast.
-Yeah, this one
is going to be a little low.
-Let's see the results.
-Whoa!
That's well-balanced.
-No, are they getting --
they get --
[ Laughter ]
That is well-balanced.
Let's take a look at
this next one. Here it says...
[ Laughter ]
As faster you can get on there,
the better.
Alright, Tariq is thinking about
that a little bit.
So, I think this might do better
than 90-something.
Let's see the results
on this one here.
[ Drum roll ]
Alright, that's not bad.
There we go.
139, I'll take that.
-Wow, 1-3-9.
-Yeah, that's good.
Alright, here we go.
The next one says...
[ Laughter ]
-Yes.
See? That was a yes.
-It does a little bit.
You're like, "Ah,
still got take Monday haze."
Okay, here we go.
Let's see the results.
[ Drum roll ]
There you go!
-Oh! There we go.
-I knew that one.
[ Cheers and applause ]
That's the winner right there!
I'm going to post this!
[ Bell dinging ]
I'm going to post this during
the commercial break.
If you see it on your feed,
give it a like,
give it a WeTweet.